[Musique]
bonjour pierre fa ire bon jean messer
caruge bonjour vous êtes donc ancien
membre de l'équipe de garcin malsa
ancien maire de sainte-anne vous avez
passé la dernière mandature comme
conseiller municipal d'opposition face
au maire qui a été élu donc en 2014
jean-michel j'ai mieux alors justement
une mandature qui a été très vite
caractérisée par justement des attaques
injustifiées ou pas vous nous direz de
de cette opposition
et ça commençait d'ailleurs dès 2014
on s'en souvient sur une question alors
ensuite il ya eu d'autres d'autres
choses mais dès 2014 vous dénonciez des
décisions prises par le nouveau conseil
municipal et notamment des le projet de
réhabilitation du camping de la pointe
marin c'est ce qui avait marqué le début
de la campagne
ce que je veux dire c'est que ensuite il
ya eu
vous avez dénoncé le non respect du
fonctionnement des instances des
conseils municipaux qui n'étaient pas
réunies en date et en heure comme il
comme il fallait
ce à quoi le maire avait ajouté par
exemple que en 2014 il y avait eu six
conseillers ses conseils municipaux qui
s'étaient tenues et que en 2015 y en
avait déjà eu 4 vous donc vous disiez et
l'ex premier adjoint de garcin malsa
expliqué que selon lui il y avait des
dérives dans la gestion municipale je
cite un albert zaïre à l'époque des
décisions arbitraires un abus de pouvoir
et d'autorité et il concluait et je
pense que vous étiez d'accord avec lui
que le maire de sainte-anne fonctionne
sans conseil municipal convoqué en bonne
et due forme alors c'est pour tout ça
que vous avez choisi de vous présenter à
cette élection municipale de 2020 pierre
haïr c'est tout ça mais c'est surtout
parce que la ville de sainte anne qui
est un joyau qui est que tout le monde
admire que tout le monde sollicite est
en train de perdre de son éclat ses deux
joyaux qui est en train de perdre de son
éclat de son éclat et effectivement ça a
commencé très tôt dans aucun niveau du
conseil municipal le maire l'homme le
nouveau maire n'avait pas une idée
précise de ce qu'est un conseiller
municipal qu'il soit d'opposition où
qu'ils soient de la majorité au conseil
municipal est là pour délibérer mais
pour poser des questions pour comprendre
ce qui se passe pour avoir des
précisions sur les délibérations qui
sont miss et monsieur michel gemon
jusqu'à l'heure où nous parlons n'a pas
encore compris je vous donne deux
exemples haut niveau dès le début nous
avons un règlement intérieur que nous
avons goûté et que nous avons amendé le
sujet michel j'ai mieux donne remet sur
le mans intérieur nous a demandé au
préfet ovalisation donc nous avons
recours il a été obligé de revenir
je vous donne 2e 2e et pour ne pas les
pouvait pas être trop long
lorsque nous votons le budget nous
devons avoir tous les éléments nous
permettant et tout l'écossé doit avoir
les éléments de leur permettant de
étudiez de comprendre et de voter
imaginez vous que à l'une des séances du
policier le budget nous avons un
document où il marque 60 pages 60 pages
explicatives du budget ce qui est
interdit et ce qui est hors la loi donc
ces deux éléments et plus d'autres vous
permettre de savoir à quel niveau nous
étions alors du coup vous avez décidé de
constituer la liste agir ensemble pour
sainte anne dont vous êtes à la tête
pierre haïr sauf que ben jean-michel
j'aime mieux voir comment dire est une
division régner pour ce scrutin au sein
du camp de l'ex maire garcin malsa
puisque il y à un autre candidat issu un
peu disons de la mouvance écologiste
écologiques politiques et écologiques et
du modemas donc il s'agit de monsieur
mais les leaks voilà je elmer hélix et
donc votre famille vous retrouve dans
une espèce de luttes intestines à sainte
anne ce qui peut être pourrez vous
handicaper pour le scrutin pour la
campagne électorale un dock à moi je
peux vous dire que je suis peut-être le
seul candidat qui ne s'est pas
autoproclamé est le seul candidat qui
n'a pas reçu l'investiture d'un homme ou
d'un leader nous avons mis en place un
processus qui a duré plus de dix
réunions sur au cours desquels nous
avons demandé qu'ils étaient candidats
pour mener la liste
nous avons eu des candidatures et à la
fin de ce processus
j'ai été désigné démocratiquement de
façon participative et de façon
collégiale
donc vous poserez la question aux autres
mais je vous explique comment
moi je suis arrivé comme tête de liste
de la liste agir ensemble pour ces dames
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez proposer
aux saintes anezho sainte anne est alors
évidemment faux résumé dit donnez nous
un ou deux exemples de propositions
fortes que vous avez pour la population
synthèse nous cette année avant de faire
des propositions
il est intéressant de savoir le
l'état des lieux un chômage de 30%
salies mille mille chômeurs à sainte
anne est donc une population qui
vieillit et une population jeune qui
diminue donc nous nous allons calquer
notre programme sur effectivement la
valorisation du travail
cette inversion du travail créer des
conditions pour l'emploi durable
renforcer l'attractivité de la ville met
en place le plan de sécurité de
prévention des risques ce qui est
important pour nous et un programme de
développement sport culture santé qui
permettra de rendre 50 plus attractif et
permettra aux jeunes de s'implanter plus
facilement
merci pierre aïm nous avons terminé ce 5
à 10 spéciales municipal réalisé par
rodrigue calix je vous remercie